so I mean Iturbide and CEO and
co-founder of lunch darkly and this is
my first time ever in Norway so I am
super excited and I'm also very excited
that I flew in yesterday
and they gave me the slot at 4 p.m.
which is 7 a.m. my time so I'm kind of
waking up right now as opposed to like a
slot earlier what I think I would have
had to had a big pot of coffee right
here super excited be in Norway super
excited to talk about feature flags
today so first a little bit more about
me I am CEO and co-founder of launch
darkly which is a company that makes the
feature flag management platform besides
that I also co-hosts a podcasts on
continuous delivery called to be
continuous with Paul bigger founder of
circle CI so if you like the talk listen
to her podcast I also write articles for
enfoque Yuri gray and ventureBeat about
just software development my background
is I started off as as an engineer so I
got an engineering degree from Harvey
Mudd College which is a school near Los
Angeles and I was an engineering program
manager for many years like all
engineers I eventually decided that I
was far smarter than my product manager
and how hard can this be
so I was sent a product manager and
within the first two months of being a
product manager I found out how wrong I
was
product management is a really hard job
the mistake I'd made as I thought
product managers just do what their
engineers tell them to do what I found
out is that there's actually a whole
world out there that makes product
management very hard not learning from
my prior lesson I then decided that how
hard can marketing be so I then went
into marketing
I actually really liked marketing
marketing has a lot more logic than you
think you basically can measure a lot of
efficiency of campaigns so engineering
fun product management hard-working fun
and I've basically seen the software
lifecycle from
every angle now out my own company I you
know we was a when we start with two
people I got to do everything else that
I hadn't already done so what I've seen
from when I started and I started
working in 1999 which is almost 20 as a
full-time job and before that I had
programmed in Visual Basic so back when
I started out releases were very seldom
so I remember one of my first Jobs was
at epicenter quit made portal management
software and we were considered really
fast because we would do a release every
year this was really fast because our
competitors like s ap would do a release
every three years and right now you're
either thinking while these dinosaurs or
ha I remember those days the really
painful thing about these long releases
was how hard it took to get feedback so
we were basically making back then we
didn't call it on-prem we just called it
software so you had to work a whole year
on your software wait for people to come
release to manufacturing wait for people
to come to downloads download site and
install it and then start using it and
then give you feedback so basically the
software you are you working on right
now somebody would probably see about a
year and a half to two years after you
started writing it this was really
painful for a lot of different reasons
perhaps the biggest one that finally
kind of changed this was that number one
there is somebody who was a little
quicker than you out there nipping at
your heels and number two these huge
releases got kind of a got to be a
burden so I was up at Microsoft last
month for the big Microsoft build
convention and Microsoft at one day had
been kind of the king of the three day
release cycles the way to described it
is when you respect one year to build
one year to test and what they
discovered that was this was forcing
them down this path of their get a year
and a half into it and the world had
changed around them but they were
already too committed to these features
they were stuck they had to ship them
because people had worked on them there
scope there already flight and then they
would ship Clippy which nobody liked you
know because hey we already have this
dancing paper clip we don't have time to
build anything else so kind of a new
world is weekly release cycles and I say
weekly there's a huge spectrum I talked
to a lot of different people out there
some people ship 20 times a day some
people ship 20 times an hour
some people are right now moving from
you know every three months to every
every two weeks the only right cadence
is the one that works for your business
but once you get that cadence double
down on it so how does this all feed
into feature flags so here's a quote
from Microsoft so feature Flags how many
people are to use feature Flags great so
feature Flags are a technique basically
where you can make part of your
application visible to some people and
not to other people this sounds really
simple at first and I'm going to talk
through some of the implications of what
that means and then I'm going to talk
about how not to use feature Flags
because feature Flags could also get you
into a lot of trouble so really what
feature Flags allow you to do is have a
unified code base and choose who gets
what access to what and so this is a
from one of our customers a laugh Ian
who talks about how to use log circley
I'll reiterate that you don't have to
use launch circley to use feature flags
we help you use them better but you
don't have to use us we're just ajust a
way to manage them alright so the
simplest way that feature Flags reduce
risk is as a kill switch so the old day
of building software was you would have
a physical release that you would put on
a production server and cross your
fingers the reason why you're crossing
your fingers is that however much you
test stuff before production you're
never going to find out anything
I mean you're never going to find
everything and this is for a variety of
reasons
so I most recently was a at TripIt as
prod
and we were test everything in our nice
labs in San Francisco
you know we'd have our blackberry phones
or Apple phones or Microsoft phones and
we would be tested everything in the
real world we had 10 million users who
are flying all over the world with low
battery a flaky internet connection and
all these things that we had never could
never anticipate so as soon as you put
something down in the real world people
are going to use your software to weigh
that even if you could anticipate it you
can't always test it that's how these
going to happen what a feature flag
allows you to do is act as an easy kill
switch so for example if there's
something where suddenly you find that
if there's a new version of Android for
example that doesn't work well and with
a your own with your application you can
say hey you know what nobody with that
Android version can see this feature
anymore this honestly gives you a great
deal of peace of mind I know it does me
the opposite is if you don't have a kill
switch something bad happens out of the
field and you're basically stuck it's
3:00 a.m. something's broken you get a
pager Duty alert there's a scramble of
I'm not going to work this is my first
time in Norway but there's this panic
loop of what happened who could fix it
what's the last known build what are we
going to do and it's a fundamental fact
of human nature that when you get into
this panic mode your brain often makes
bad decisions so some of the worst
software releases mistakes I've seen
happen is with them and I'll own this up
this happened to me we ships updates we
ship something that was actually
destroying customers data just at all
let's let's do a fix pack so we did this
really hurried fix pack that six pack
broke this other thing over here that we
hadn't really thought about because
we're just ready to do this one thing
okay let's do this other fix pack within
about eight hours we've gone from a to H
before we finally contained the bleeding
and this wasn't a fun experience for
anybody so if we
add a feature flag back then what we
could have simply said is you know what
something is broken let's stop it let's
assess how we're going to fix it let's
think about this let's have a clean six
so you think kill switches basically
allow you to decouple feature rollout
from Co deployment so that you can
really take your time if something goes
wrong a really good technique to use
with feature flags as a controlled
rollout this is basically where you're
rolling out a feature from zero to 100%
of your traffic the preferred time to
use this as a fast anything performance
related you for example might have a
search query that performs really well
when one person hits it every two hours
like you might in a QA environment but
completely degrades suddenly you have a
million people querying every five
minutes so a controlled rollout allows
you to slowly push something out to your
user base see how they respond and also
turn it back down so Pedro Duty actually
talked about this in another talk I saw
which is awesome which some they use
feature flags to roll stuff out in the
morning and then at lunchtime they turn
it back to zero and when asked about why
at lunchtime it was zero they're like we
don't want to respond an incident at
lunchtime you know like let's let's I
want to go to lunch at peace sounds
really obvious right like you want to go
to lunch with these so with controlled
rollouts what they could do is they can
turn it up to 25% and 30% before lunch
turn it off at lunch come back and then
after through the afternoon continue and
monitor what controller oh let's really
let you do is make software releases
work for you instead of vice versa
another really fun thing to do with
feature flags is that you could give
early access to your best customers
again Microsoft does this a lot
they call them canary releases what they
do is they can have people opt in to
different rings of a release so if
you're basically the person who wants
the latest the greatest no matter how
flaky it is you can get that you can
actually go into visual studio now and
flip
different features that you want early
access to what surprising thing that I
found is that people really like getting
early access to things we use this
internally at lunch Derek Romero and
company we had a new SSO feature we were
building and people were so excited
about getting it early that they were
really willing to give us a lot of early
feedback we also did this a lot of
TripIt we had this new feature which was
extremely risky at the time which was we
were scraping your Gmail in boxes three
basics basically walking into your Gmail
inbox looking for travel confirmations
and then importing them into TripIt this
was considered very risky at the time
because basically nobody else was doing
this o else was pretty new we didn't
know how big people's inboxes would be
and we didn't know the quality of our
own algorithms very thoroughly so what
we could do is we could often have
people about five to ten very early
early adopter travelers select to be
part of this I gave us a lot of feedback
and that was great so I was the product
first at the time and what we found out
was that uh
we could do some really quick algorithm
switches such as a at the beginning we
would scrape anything that looks like a
ticket so and a lot of like we would for
example accidentally scraped gift
certificates and advertisements people
don't like but it was fine because we
had these early adopters who just kind
of said hey these are garbage throw them
out early adopters could be your best
friends the other thing you could do is
you could block people from getting
early early releases I just said right
now that people love getting early
releases there are also people who hate
getting early releases usually this will
happen in a b2b company where you have
some customers who have a lot of
training around your current features
and they do not want to get and your
release just know just don't bug them
stripe is a great example of this
they're not a lot of strictly customer
but I know that they stripe as a service
for an API that powers a lot of
basically credit card systems
if you have a bartender out of the field
with an iPad you do not want to subtly
change the entire layout on them this
could cause chaos so what they'll do is
they'll block a lot of features to the
general population so they could get
them exactly right before they push them
out so blocking features is actually
really powerful another way you could do
this is you could block different IPS
you could block different email
addresses you could just block whoever
you want so great use cases for this are
CEOs sometimes you don't want them to
see stuff til it's really baked because
they'll give you a lot of half-baked
commentary you might want to block tech
blogs for example TechCrunch you don't
might not want them to see you a feature
early you might just want to also block
for example if you know if an editor is
looking at your software you could block
their IP you can block an email domain
you could block anything that you want
so feature flags at summer this really
great technique to really be couple to
decrease risk of a software so let me
now that I've talked about how great
feature flags are let me talk about how
they could be extremely dangerous and
how you should be really careful when
you're using them okay so I gave you the
bright shiny Korena of feature flags now
I'm going to tell you the dark side
feature Flags a really great technique
if you're really trying to have a
unified code base where you don't want
to have a long live branch out there
that's kind of good cause a lot of
hassle when you merge it back in however
if you're not vigilant about how you're
using feature Flags if you use them
poorly you can have a real disaster on
your hand so night capital is a US firm
I see a couple nods where a poor use of
feature flags caused them to lose about
half a billion dollars in an hour so
half a billion US dollars which is
basically I get my conversion right four
billion Crona
I think it's right that's a lot of money
that's a lot of money for software to
lose very quickly so how they lost it
and this is basically the gyrations that
they caused was and this whole effort
that's full article for enfoque you with
the full story if you want it
they had a feature flag called powder
pigs and their code that they had never
pulled out somebody thought powder peg
did something else so when they shipped
it when they pushed a version of
software this thing should always have
been off it was basically something they
used on a staging server because they
wanted to test that trades were
executing very rapidly so if they turn
on powder peg basically executed trades
very quickly together this is great in
staging if you're trying to simulate a
real load however when they pushed it to
production with it on it was the system
didn't know that they were not on a
staging server and what happened was
they started executing trades extremely
rapidly which is what you can see right
here basically the sort of the market
throwing and chaos into the trading when
they try to fix this it actually turns
another feature flag on and further
destabilize the system so it took them
about two hours to fix this whole thing
and in the meantime a lot of money was
lost there's a lot of lessons to learn
from this and I'm going to walk through
them one by one
all right ambiguously named Flags never
have a flag that has an ambiguous name
powder peg is an awful name like if
you're starting to use feature Flags
think of a good Naveen suggestion from
the beginning this is kind of like the
the reverse of a it's really common when
you had back when you name servers to
give them cutesy names you know like
Orion oh and Apollo do not do this with
feature flags never have a situation
where you have oh this feature flag
named Apollo what is that - they don't
don't give them code names that somebody
could mistake particularly when they're
tired have a really clear convention of
for example
you know server-side setting and then
what it actually does assume that
whoever is looking at your feature Flags
including you two weeks later will have
no idea what it does this can also
prevent the case and I've seen this
happen where you have two different
teams they assume that the flag does
different things I heard this story in
London where two different teams both
thought their feature flag could control
their part of the software so you had a
back-end team and a front-end team and
every release they would basically
alternate flipping it took them a long
time to sort this out never never never
allow yourself to get in a situation
where people can be confused and even if
they are really clear people will still
be confused so try to comment out names
and explain them over use flags it
happens so what happened in this case I
love this this is a real plan I got off
the internet but in this case I'm an
engineer and you know what probably
happened is that they have a single fuse
that's controlling both their elevator
and a light switch sounds great when
you're wiring something up right not so
great if you're in the elevator when
somebody wants to turn the lights off
you know make very clear when you're
using a flag what it should it should it
control don't have it threaded
throughout it don't have it threaded
throughout and controlling random things
that might not sync on the other hand
sometimes you do want to have kind of a
master switch a really great use case
for this is a for example if you're
doing a rebranding so when you if you do
a rebranding which is pretty much a
hopefully a once every two to three
things not a once every six months thing
you'll have a lot of assets that you
want to control with the same feature
flag you know you have all your email
templates you'll have all your front-end
you probably will have some back-end
coding so thanks very carefully about
why you're having one feature flag
control a lot of things sometimes it's a
good idea sometimes it can put you in a
lot of trouble
conflicting flags so this is a US
traffic sign do you know if you could
park here or not no this can happen if
you have different groups working on a
different feature different parts list
system and usually this happens when
they're actually all kind of controlled
off their own config file what can
happen really easily is particularly if
you have this distributed team is one
person could think they're controlling
something one person can think they're
controlling something and the result is
chaos for example if you have a back end
and a front-end team and you have a new
feature like to go back to the search
one and once they still control who can
see the search via just turning off that
box and they still control the search
via nice error message if you have two
flags which both people think are
controlling something they start
flicking the most benign thing is it
just doesn't appear if it's something
more serious for example something in
your billing process it can actually
take you a long time to figure out why
whatever is happening isn't the right
way so when you are using Flags I think
this goes back to the ambiguously named
that overused put them in a common place
usually where people run into trouble as
if each each team has them own not only
are there no naming conventions but in
their own system config files are
usually the worst offender config file
sounds fun until they're not the issue
of config files is that you start to
proliferate them and they're very hard
then to track down that this config file
is actually controlling something else
that broke your thing over there but
then trigger it into this and now it's 4
a.m. and you're like what the all
right
I don't know how many years I don't know
if these are funny if you're not
American but this is this is a real
story this was a content management
company that I know well they had a
feature flag so they'd started using
feature flags pretty much at the
beginning and they got a little more
sophisticated actually built kind of an
admin panel so a simple UI so that
anybody in our company could turn future
flags on and off sounds great right you
don't have to go bug your developer
anymore you don't have to depend on a
config file there's this easy admin
thing however it was a little too easy
so at the end of the day feature flags
are really controlling core
functionality when your application and
they basically had this admin page that
anything that company could turn on and
off any feature this was really benign
until it wasn't so one day suddenly and
nobody could upload a file anymore this
is actually a big deal if your content
management system and nobody can upload
a file so there is these panicked calls
to customer support and sort of
escalating and got actually the CEO CEO
calls the company says you know we need
to figure this out immediately
nobody can upload a file after about I
think they told me was three hours they
figured out that they had an old feature
flag I was troll on the admin page that
somebody had accidentally turned off and
this feature flag stop people from
uploading I'm sure they'd originally had
good intentions of putting this in I
think they had wanted to throttle
traffic you know if they're just simply
overwhelmed by spammers they want to be
able to shut off all uploads
however they left this thing in which
somebody could basically their
entire system so they had to then you
know just simply turn it back on
everything started working again but
this was three hours of like people
calling a CEO being extremely upset and
the funniest part is story to me was I
asked well did they then take the
feature flag off the UI and they said no
we didn't know what really worked for so
we had to leave it
they're like did you put more security
on it no no we just put this big label
that said do not ever touch this button
and then they kind of put like and then
about they said about six months later
it happened again where nobody could
upload files and this time they knew
that they just had to go to this feature
flag on the on the UI and turn it back
on it was like well did you finally take
it off and like know we put even bigger
letters because we tweeted in like yo
sis like I'm you know so don't don't get
yourself with this situation where
you're letting everybody control your
application and you don't even know who
they never figured out who flipped it
and quite honestly I don't think it
really matters who flipped it you know I
think it wasn't really that person's
fault they were put in a situation where
there was a lever that they shouldn't
have been able to touch it's kind of
like it's kind of like why when trains
everybody doesn't have access to the
brake you know because like everybody
will be touching the brake accidentally
alright left over flags no does it's not
my own refrigerator this is really the
worst knock against feature flags and I
gotta agree with it feature flags with
this incredibly powerful tool but if you
keep using them you'll keep accumulating
them so I know of people who use feature
flags basically for every full request
that's a lot I know other people who use
them just for major features or minor
features still if you're not careful you
can start to accumulate a lot of feature
flags and what happens when you have a
lot of feature flags is you're basically
accumulating a lot of technical debt
you're creating branches where you're
not creating branches but you're
creating paths that QA might have to
test your adding ambiguity of how they
might interact with other pieces of your
code and you're you're just so up to
actually create a little bit of risk
that somebody accidentally flip a flag
they shouldn't flip
don't have leftover flags every time
when you're thinking about a feature
think about how long that flag should
live I mean so this is what ultimately
brought down night capital is that even
if they had had a really clear name even
if they've been better about labeling
they still had a leftover flag when they
didn't when they should have pulled that
flag out a long time ago and same with
the story that's told about the content
management story content management
system they had a leftover flag but
nobody knew what it did so just like you
always have good intentions when you put
a leftover in your fridge when you pull
it out three weeks later you don't want
that leftover anymore it's been in the
fridge a little bit too long there are a
lot of cases where you would want to
keep a feature flag around what I found
a lot of that feature flags will cross
between being something that a back end
I'm a developer is using to mitigate
risk to be in more of a user setting so
let me give you an example
there's a lot of one-offs in the world
no matter how much you want to avoid
them I've had one offs work for example
work and Stanley sign a contract with us
where they always got this special thing
and it wasn't something that we wanted
to put out to the rest of our customers
so we basically had a feature flag error
system that Morgan Stanley always gets
this that was a good feature flag it was
a necessary feature flag because we
basically were making that if you do
start to use these kind of feature flags
for more user settings or for example
another one as if you want your power
users after they've logged in 20 times
you get access to a special feature or
if you want for example want somebody
who buys frequently to get better access
make really sure that you're doing this
for a good consistent reason and you're
not just having something you should
pull out of your code all right
so recipe for effective feature flag
driven development number one slide
carefully I think a lot about why you're
using a flag and a question I ask right
now I usually get asked is well how
often should a flag and my main answer
is whatever your development team is
most comfortable with that's the right
cadence if you're just getting started
with feature flagging the right cadence
is usually about once every sprint until
your team gets used to how to use them
how they work for them a lot of it then
also is who gets access to them for
example you don't really want your UI
team to be able to turn off or throttle
a back-end feature so think about who
gets access think about why they get
access and build that into your thought
process whenever you're starting a new
feature the second thing you really want
to do is you want to lock down access to
feature flags and people do this a lot
of different ways the biggest the
easiest the cheapest way to lock down
access is to throw them into a config
file this is kind of a trap because you
might think oh if they're in a config
file that means that nobody who's not a
developer touch it however config files
usually don't have much access control
on them so this actually leaves you
really vulnerable to a lot of mistakes
if you're using a config file to control
access what that means that you're
similarly prone to typos to be able to
pull down a release
also if usually config files you
generally have to redeploy to have them
the changes picked up so it negates the
benefit of using a feature flag until
switch so for example if you want to do
a controlled rollout and it's at a good
big file every time you want to change
it for example from 0 to 10 to 15 to 20
after redeploy that's quite expensive so
config files usually seem like a cheap
and easy way to lock down access they're
actually kind of a trap it doesn't
really get you what you want the next
way that people usually lock down access
is they'll use a database
this is a little bit better
however databases can then also start to
be expensive and I mean expensive in
terms of time if every time you have to
check it whether features on an hour off
or someone you have to make a database
call so the best way to to lock down
access is to really have some sort of
system that actually manages it and also
something along with that is to have an
audit log not so that you have somebody
to blame
at least lets you have somebody to talk
to so the examples I gave of different
teams of different teams using the same
flag I was somebody turning a flag
accidentally off none of these were
malicious I don't think anybody wakes up
and says today is the day that I really
want to cause a production error and
cause people to call my CEO in a panic
usually errors happen because people
didn't understand and the system they
were using let themself get into a state
where it wasn't clear how something
worked so I don't log it's really just
that you could go talk to something to
say hey what do you do this remove flags
I can't say this enough if you're done
with a flag get it out of there it's
kind of like the old rule of them if
you've eaten your dinner go clean the
dishes it seems like it adds a step but
if you don't clean your dishes
the next day you're going to go try to
cook and there's going to be all these
dishes in your kitchen and picture that
except for instead of like a day's worth
of dishes there is 365 days worth of
dishes and not only that all the dishes
from everybody who had ever even dinner
in that kitchen
that sounds pretty gross right you're so
cleanup feature flags not just to
protect yourself but to protect the rest
of your team you really want to make it
so that you're being a good a good team
member not leaving around old flags a
story I heard again all these I
personally heard I loved by the way I
love bad feature flag stories if you
have any come talk to me
some I really enjoy hearing them so
another story I heard is a person this
Bay this guy personally left his company
his Alert schita
he basically tuned an entire ad-serving
system using feature flags so basically
they were taking traffic in and then
reselling it to other people and pushing
out just the right ad to the right
person
and he'd built all sorts of tuning into
feature feature flags but he'd stored
them all and I could sync file so
basically uh you know this person gets
10% this publisher gets 20% and tuning
the mix with that when he left his job
the next person didn't understand what
any of this stuff was for didn't there
nothing was commented or documented so
he just turned everything every feature
flag to zero this is not good so
basically publishers suddenly got all
this bad traffic they shut them off
entirely lost the company not a half
billion dollars but probably about 300k
in a day when my friend told me this and
I say the word friend loosely his his
take was haha that idiot messed up my
feature flags I was like no you should
never have a system that somebody could
make a mistake like that you should have
documented these feature flags they
should have good names and you should
have like left in a place where your
next person understands what they do
ultimately his he was kind of my sense
he thought the person next the person
behind him was stupid I'm like no you
are stupid for letting a fellow
developer get in trouble like always
always think about the person who is
using these feature flags after you and
whether they'll be in shape to
understand them so let me let me finish
by telling a story about good feature
flags and then I actually I left a lot
of times I loved questions and I loved
any horror stories you have
good feature flags I think are one of
the best tools of development there are
and let me talk about how they help from
concept to launch any feature is risky
at the beginning and the biggest risk is
does anybody care about this at all you
know I have everybody's felt the pain of
you know poor in a lot of time maybe a
couple weekends maybe several months or
years of weekends and to feature that it
turns out nobody actually cares about
and as an engineer this is actually one
of the most painful things that can ever
happen this is actually why I became a
product manager because it was tired of
building features that nobody wanted
thankful with future flags we could do
is you could take kind of a baby feature
a proto feature and start asking a
couple people do you like this - like
this - like this is what you're thinking
about the old way of doing releases
where you release every three years this
was just simply impossible because you
would have this with this feedback
window every three years so of course
you had to build everything to the
biggest extent if you have an
opportunity to build more of a Minimum
Viable Product you could build that
little feature very quickly like maybe
only in a two days or two hours or two
weeks and start showing it to different
people the other thing you do with
feature flags is you can do this right
in your main branch in the old days you
would have these branches out which are
very painful because you would have to
basically build a branch out and then
merge it back in very tediously with a
feature flag even if you have something
kind of half-baked you can just build it
right in your main branch off and then
control who sees it so this is this is
what for example we didn't trip it with
the email scraping project we could just
push it to a couple people very early
the risk you have after that is will it
break out in the field like once you've
gotten some sort of surety of this is a
good feature people seem to like it now
you have the next level of risk oh and
not only do people like it not only do
people like the field but it didn't
break all of my other developers stuff
your
is no good if it breaks other features
in your codebase then there's a next
step which is do people who I didn't
explicitly ask to see this feature are
they cool with it too and that's when
you can start to do more of a rollout
and push it to different people and in
the final usual step that people worry
about the most but actually happens the
least is does it perform under load the
reason why most I'll just say this most
people care too much about performance
that because the biggest risk any
feature have is that nobody ever uses it
so I think there's always a political
yes that does happen I've been there
that sucked
usually what's going to happen is ten
people are going to show up so this is
why you test performance glass at the
end and again a feature flag helps you
what feature flags help you do with all
of this is that you can carefully
control who gets access at the right
time so the very earliest stage it could
be only other developers to get access
than QA then you I usually and then beta
users out on the field and then more and
more and more people and at every step
you don't have to spin up a separate
server you don't have to you don't have
to get people to go to special beta
build it's all just in your unified
codebase but the key to all of this is
if you remember three things slide
carefully lock down access to who can
change them and be really sure to remove
flags at the end so questions so also if
you like a launch directly t-shirt we
have them at just go to a spot and I'll
again emphasize lunch directly is a
platform that really helps you a feature
flagging you do not have to use us to
use any of the tips I just shared we
make it easier but I hope this is the
things that you can incorporate into
your own development practice even if
you don't use us so questions